good morning so what you doing clean
with Maya hey cutie good morning guys
let's hook up gotta get the boy ready
for school by the way this video is
sponsored by Chromebook Thank You
Chromebook so let's go check out the boy
good morning baby
oh just turn off your light good morning
bristle big now you know you're like
super big like you're almost as tall as
me like pretty soon you're gonna be
taller than me
I can't believe it you gotta stop
growing daddy went to go get more lunch
supplies because we just realized that
we ran out of bread and ham and cheese
no wonder cuz I was like oh you saw him
leave yeah yes Isaac been making his own
breakfast recently he he learned how to
make eggs on the pan make some scrambled
eggs and it just makes me feel like he's
just growing up so fast
breakfast and everything what does he
leave me for anymore okay whoa look at
you handling the fire and everything
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you like making your own eggs now
yeah it's like a war zone up
that millions a little raw eggs a la
Isaac
[Music]
you know what you've had this plate in
this cup like this set here you've had
it since you were a baby so it's about
ten years old oh yeah it's starting to
show its age now make sure you eat
scrambled eggs like all the way to me it
tastes too plain mm-hmm I'll have to put
a salt and pepper because I'm used to
people putting salt and pepper
when they scrambled it but when Daddy
makes the eggs like these adds a little
more flavor right yeah it's not fully
cooked yeah
do you remember when I used to make you
eggs mm-hm you don't remember you're so
little
I used to make you eggs every morning
just like now how you're making them all
on your own I would make them just the
way you like I'm like this really yeah
okay oh yeah look like yolk like not
fully fully cooked still a little bit
fluffy and raw don't forget stick your
gum you guys are like one last blockade
for 19 countries the previous night
rushing down a Russian and then I'm
getting through the door than all the
cats are like you made it I made it
isaac check this you know what it is
it's a Chromebook have you ever played
with the Chromebook before yeah really
work at school
that's so cool what do you do with your
Chromebook that's cool we basically like
take tests where you
research research you know so cool so we
went to Isaac's open house a few weeks
back and we did see that he's been using
Chromebooks in my classroom and then
it's so cool that they have this program
on there where it's kind of like social
media but for their classroom so they
have a whole class on there and then
they up they record videos of themselves
for their projects and then they upload
it to this like social media platform
that's only for their school the reason
why I like social media is because you
can actually like and comment on
people's like uploads and their projects
and stuff and I saw Isaac oh is the
thing that you uploaded me presenting my
project for you guys I know it's so cute
okay you're so have a stylist there's a
button right there click it and I pull
it up that cool cuz it's own stylist and
then you can just touch the whole thing
cool I just like a key take this off uh
you can actually flip it so flip the
keyboard back all the way like a tablet
so I could be like that yeah you can use
it like a tablet
you know what we can use this next time
you have a report yeah can we get
minecraft on this I don't know I kind of
want you to use it more for school I'm
such a mom fun using the stylus huh
you could even use your finger too if
you want all right you ready baby
yep dad take you to school Isaac do you
want to take the Chromebook in the car
so you could play on the way to school
he's probably thinking hey guys it you
want to take the Carver to school I'm
gonna do you have music class today oh
so you don't need your violin oh thank
you oh never mind it I thought you're
opening the door for me
[Music]
bye ru de alright guys now we came to
the Huntington Library and pathetical
garden but yeah so we're here to do a
photo shoot Casey's been wanting to flex
on his photography skills for a while
now and I've been wanting to practice
trying to be a model because I feel like
honestly if I had more practice I
wouldn't be as awkward in front of the
camera when it comes to taking photos
we're here to get some practice in yeah
and this place the Huntington Library
and Botanical Garden is a perfect place
for where people come all the time to
come and do photo shoots you know what I
realize is that you and I both we if
there's something interesting happening
in our lives where you just stop posting
something exciting yeah cuz I mean
mundane day-to-day things I personally
don't like taking a lot of selfies and
stuff if you guys have noticed I rarely
post selfies or just photos of myself I
don't know it just feels really
narcissistic even though that's our
professions a lot of people these days
just take a million selfies and post a
selfie every single day and I look at
girls I could do that I'm like hey
that's so cool I can't do that I get
tired of my fame I only have one luck
when I take a selfie it's cheese and
that's it like I don't know how to do
different looks and so that's why I want
to try to practice my modeling skills
see if I got it I know some fire today
this is that thing we're gonna nail some
fire nail some fire huh
we're gonna nail it today and make some
fire how about that but we put it all
together now bring your nails on fire
yeah I brought an umbrella for this
maybe I should busted over yeah I have a
son allergies and that crazy I developed
it in my mid-20s weird I should not be
allergic to the Sun but since I am I
should not be in the Sun so directly
he's hurt it did put sunscreen on plates
just makes me want to do a somersault do
a somersault real quick hold on hold on
a second I'm a pretty self reflective
person and I get very introspective and
I talk a lot about how old I'm getting
and like I'm losing touch with youth in
what's what's popular and trending now
and then Tiff's always complaining about
how I'm always talking about how old I'm
getting look who's old now [ __ ] the
youth out of my life I'm just like I
want to still feel young it sounds like
this I'm like I gotta be realistic okay
that's time I tried doing it actually
sprained my thighs or I don't know what
happened but my thigh started hurting
[Music]
she's so cute
[Music]
how's the photo pusher going so far cool
I guess I don't know I'm really my own
worst critic so I feel like I've been
trying to pull off he's really like sexy
kind of looks I just don't have it I
just can't my face just can't do it in
my opinion I just can't pull off the
sultry look I think I've just accepted
the fact that my face can only do a
happy smiling kind of poses that's it I
don't think I have enough lips and I
think my butt chin is too buddy
my question to like really come off
really like I can't do it I look cool I
don't know I think you're nice does he
love me and you see the sexy in here I
can't be it I think there's a lot of
people that can see the sexy in there I
don't yeah so whenever I look I review
the photos I'm like delete delete delete
it just doesn't work
[Music]
[Laughter]
third thing it should I get for being
silly models got it tough man I used to
think it was so easy being a model it's
like oh what's so hard about that just
look pretty and angle your body and
that's it but nah man this is work and I
don't even know my angle its imagine if
I did know my angles and if I knew how
to replicate these faces be like you
just did it all right I got tired of
taking part we actually brought more
clothes for me to change into look yeah
more look at a call brother right sorry
we're look I'm not a professional model
I don't know this I don't know these
things but yeah so we brought more looks
but then Ellen Casey I'm like this is
exhausting like I already like I'm tired
it is chill and it's so warm the weather
is freakin perfect all right so now I'm
gonna edit some photos and get your
Instagram on point yeah I've actually
brought the Chromebook with me yay so
we've had the Chromebook for a couple
weeks and I've seen you play with it a
lot do you have you liked it yeah I
really like just because it's kind of
like it's like a cross between a laptop
and a tablet or like a phone everyone
knows that this is a sponsored video but
honestly guys even though this is a
sponsored video they did ask us to just
be truthful and give our honest opinion
so honestly though what are your
thoughts on the couple well like how
light it is it's like a simplified
laptop and like it lasts like ten hours
on a single charge so I don't actually
have to bring the video we didn't bring
the charger with us today either and
it's perfect for everything we need to
do and we're out and about and I can
actually start editing the photos right
here your friends beautiful koi pond
this is the thing that makes this so
much better than anything else
I actually the stylist I picked this one
photo I don't know you don't know
dang it this is pretty cool there's so
much control over at the editing at the
photo I think the size of the screen
actually helps a lot
Sibella see the clarity and the contrast
that you're applying because of what's
just wearing and how the Sun is this
photos really warm so I'm going to cool
it down a little bit and push the
temperature corset blues and then
there's a lot of highlights that are
blown out in her hair and I'm gonna
pulled up White's down the highlights
down to kind of make that a little more
natural look into the eye and then
there's one thing I don't like about the
camera I use is the fact that everything
turns out a little greener than it
should be so with the tint I'm gonna
push the heels towards the magenta side
but photo editing is made easier when
you have a beautiful wife it's pretty
cool you guys check it out check out the
description below and we have some info
there for you if you're interested so
now we're just gonna relax and enjoy the
view I'm sorry you know it's so cute
about Casey
every time he concentrates he has a
person's lips showing you're
concentrated look come on you know you
want a purse there we go
there we go you're fighting it vogue is
here okay sorry I'll let you at it who's
that my wife now you know the answer
second time's the charm
[Music]